en este vídeo vamos a pensar un poquito
sobre la gráfica de la función ye igual
a la raíz cuadrada de x y aquí estamos
pensando en la raíz principal verdad es
decir cuando tomamos un valor positivo
de esta raíz cuadrada y por supuesto
tenemos que hablar del dominio de esta
función y vamos a considerar lo que es
el dominio natural es decir cuáles son
todos aquellos valores x para la cual
esta función está definida y eso es para
todos los números mayores o iguales que
0 verdad porque sólo podemos sacar raíz
cuadrada a números que sean mayores o
iguales que 0 es decir a números que
sean no negativos muy bien y ahora lo
que quiero que pensemos es qué pasaría
por ejemplo si nosotros queremos
trasladar la gráfica de esta función y
para eso necesitamos ver cómo es la
gráfica por ejemplo cuando x vale 0 nos
encontramos o bueno vale 0 verdad cuando
x vale 1 tenemos la raíz de 1 que es 1
cuando x vale 4 la raíz cuadrada de 4
pues es 2 cuando x vale 9 la raíz
cuadrada de 9 es 3 y ahí tenemos más o
menos los puntos que nos definen la
gráfica de esta función y que estoy
haciendo mi mejor esfuerzo para
pintarlas lo mejor posible muy bien
entonces más o menos ahí lo tienen ahí
está la gráfica de esta función al menos
hasta el 9 verdad
ahí está entonces decíamos qué pasaría
si nosotros quisiéramos por ejemplo
trasladar la gráfica de esta función
cuatro unidades hacia arriba entonces
por ejemplo vamos a seleccionarla y
nosotros queremos trasladarla hacia
arriba que íbamos a copiarla
y la trasladamos 4 unidades hacia arriba
ahí está entonces si nosotros queremos
hacer eso tenemos que dar la ecuación de
esta nueva gráfica y eso pues pensemos
si ahora en vez de 0 quiero que va algo
que valga 4 y que en cada punto ahora le
sumamos 4 unidades pues entonces la
gráfica de esta nueva función es la raíz
cuadrada de x pero le sumamos 4 y de
hecho vamos a rellenarla un poquito con
azul para que se entienda de que
funcione estamos hablando muy bien y
esto no fue nada complicado verdad
incluso si nosotros quisiéramos
trasladar más unidades hacia arriba o
hacia abajo sólo sumamos ese número muy
bien ahora qué pasa si nosotros
quisiéramos esta gráfica trasladarla
pero hacia la izquierda
por ejemplo pensemos que ahora queremos
trasladar las tres unidades a la
izquierda digamos que se quede por ahí
muy bien entonces como podríamos hacer
eso bueno pensemos que ahora en vez de
que el en cero valga cero necesito que
en menos tres valga cero es decir que le
tengo que sumar a menos 3 para que me dé
entonces podemos ver que si yo tomo x +
3 en menos 3 vale 0 ahora si yo tomo la
raíz cuadrada de esta forma entonces
estoy haciendo que por ejemplo para que
valga la función
qué será por ejemplo cuando vale
si yo quiero por ejemplo que esto valga
1 necesito que x + 3 valga 1 entonces
ahora en menos sería en menos 2 ahora va
a valer 1 verdad es decir con esta
fórmula lo que estamos consiguiendo es
que ahora la gráfica se ha trasladado
hacia la izquierda y voy a rellenar esto
así y entonces hemos trasladado esta
gráfica hacia la izquierda tres unidades
y en general uno podría hacer esto para
cualquier función si yo quiero por
ejemplo trasladar no sé digamos 10
unidades a la izquierda pues tengo que
sumar 10 y esto puede parecer anti
intuitivo porque sumar me mueve a la
izquierda y esto es porque en realidad
tenemos que pensar que si ahora quiero
que en menos 3 valga 0 pues aquí le
tengo que sumar a menos 3 para que me dé
justamente 0 que era donde donde
teníamos que la función valía 0 muy bien
qué tal que nosotros ya no queremos
trasladar esta técnica ya digamos ya la
revisamos qué tal que ahora esta gráfica
roja la quiero
digamos voltear de esta forma ahora
quiero que digamos que se vea más o
menos así más o menos así aquí está 1234
aquí tienen que valer dos más más o
menos que se vea así
más o menos de esta forma muy bien
estamos pensando en esta misma gráfica
pero ahora reflejada hacia la izquierda
muy bien cómo le hacemos entonces para
poder reescribir esto entonces pensemos
que ahora de dónde debe estar definido
es para todos los valores que sean
menores o iguales que menos 3 entonces
lo que aquí estos están definidos para
todos los valores mayores o iguales que
menos 3 abajo de menos 3 esto nos da un
número negativo y no está definido ahora
quiero que no esté definido para los
mayores o iguales que menos 3 perdón
para los estrictamente mayores que menos
3 entonces eso se soluciona si nosotros
multiplico multiplicamos por menos a
dentro de la raíz verdad porque fíjate
que muy bien que esto es algo negativo
por este número entonces para que lo de
adentro sea mayor o igual que 0
necesitamos que x más 3 sea menor o
igual que 0 y eso quiere decir que deben
ser menores o iguales qué
3 muy bien entonces aquí tenemos ya esta
misma gráfica pero digamos reflejada con
respecto a esta a esta línea punteada
que pusimos de verde muy bien ahora bien
qué tal si por ejemplo queremos esta
misma gráfica pero reflejada con
respecto al eje x es decir que tengamos
algo así
3 más aquí está el otro punto
muy bien más o menos que se vea así
que esta gráfica que se vea más o menos
así muy bien entonces lo que está
pasando es que ahora estamos reflejando
con respecto al eje x es decir en vez de
tomar los valores positivos que nos
arroja esta función
ahora vamos a tomar los los valores
negativos muy bien y simplemente se
queda exactamente igual la función pero
ahora tomamos los valores negativos a
ver finalmente y te invito a que a que
tú lo intentes que pasaría no no
queremos eso vamos a seleccionar esta
misma gráfica vamos a seleccionar esta
gráfica ok
a copiar y pegar qué pasaría si nosotros
quisiéramos poner esto pero digamos que
serán unas 4 unidades abajo
digamos que estemos por aquí muy bien
entonces cuál sería la la ecuación de
esta gráfica la ecuación correspondiente
a esta gráfica pues justamente como lo
hicimos en el primer caso simplemente
tomamos la la ecuación que ya teníamos
ya igual a menos la raíz de menos x 3
esa corresponde a esta morada y ahora
queremos trasladar 4 hacia abajo
entonces simplemente restamos 4 y así
podríamos seguir por siempre pero espero
que con estos ejemplos tengas una gran
perspectiva de cómo manipular estas
funciones haremos muchos más ejemplos
para alcanzar un mejor entendimiento de
todo ello